[Music]
thanks for stopping by the pretty
intense podcast I am honored and
delighted to have a very good friend of
mine Kelly Gore's on the show today
we've been friends since I watched her
documentary heal on Netflix long time
ago I think it might have came out like
2016 and I remember posting something on
social media about it on Instagram and
tagged her and she was like oh hey you
know thank you and we became friends and
and of course we have the same birthday
so we totally get along she recently had
an explant
um of her breast implants and obviously
that's something that I just recently
did and and me doing it played uh some
part in in her doing it as well and so
today's conversation was the first time
she's talked about that publicly and and
how it went and why she did it in the
first place with getting implants as
well as why she got them out the things
that she dealt with and what she feels
like is better now um and then we got
into some great sort of like
philosophical conversation about mental
and physical wellness about forgiveness
about men and women the masculine
feminine it was a just a really like
well-spirited conversation about the
things going on in the world and like
what the hell we can do about them and
what the next steps are so enjoy the
show with Kelly and please hit subscribe
and the bell for notifications when we
have a show come out and as always I
love to see what you have to say in the
comments I'm really grateful that you
wanted to do this interview I'm grateful
that you want to talk about getting your
implants out and I I I I really think
this is well it actually just came last
night from doing an interview for a
documentary being made called busted and
um so I just I'm like fresh off of
talking about it myself but what I was
telling them is I'm like it just feels
like because they've been work she's
been working on it for four years and I
was like but if this came out a couple
years ago I feel like it wouldn't have
been as impactful because it feels like
right now there's just a lot of talk
about it and um so anyway this interview
is right on time the docs are right on
time so uh I think it's best to I don't
always go in order
um but I do think that it's appropriate
for in the spirit of implants to go back
in time to like just explain like why
you did it you know like when did you do
it and why did you do it so 12 years ago
I guess 2010
I had always I'd never like thought
about getting implants but I'd always
been self-conscious of my shoulders
um just proportionally like I was pretty
proportioned kid but people always
commented you know are you a swimmer
you're my your shoulders are so big my
arms were just big you know that was my
perception and
um and then I was pretty flat ultimately
I just wanted to be in proportion you
know I wanted to feel like a woman as I
went through this whole journey of
making the decision you know because you
inspired me to do so which is so awesome
I was
um thinking back I was like trying to do
the whole healing process of like what
what really got me to do it I mean in
2010 it was because I was sick of being
out of proportion and I wanted to feel
more feminine but what what was it back
in the day and I remember this boy that
I'm still friends with today he was like
my first love
it was in eighth grade eighth to ninth
grade and he made I think it was in
eighth grade and he made a comment about
how flat I was because everybody around
me was you know going through puberty I
was a much later Bloomer and
you know back like looking back it means
nothing to me but I remember being
absolutely devastated
and then you know I went like I went
through puberty probably two three years
after most of my girlfriends and he had
a girlfriend at the time who had gone
through puberty in eighth grade and
is the thief of Joy exactly so Joy
ripped from me and then you know there
was just this subconscious little trauma
that I had suppressed so at the time I
and I and I was an actor at the time and
so I remember telling my surgeon please
I don't want big boobs I just want shape
it was more of just like I was a full
bee but I I but they were just like they
weren't they were just not doing
anything they weren't perky they weren't
doing anything so I was like I just want
a little more shape and to be more
proportionate and so before I went under
I was like I know you tell me I want
more I don't want more I'm I'm blonde if
you give me bigger boobs I'm gonna just
be Typecast as a bimbo and that's the
end of my career so
um so I got really small implants how
small were they I had 213 that's what
mine were yeah I think mine was around
that too that's not big right no no it
most most don't go much under 300. yeah
I think mine was like somewhere like 210
to 220. yeah that's pretty small so you
have the same set so you only ever had
one set only had one set 12 years I
remember someone tell they were silicone
this is before the FDA banned silicone
or did you somehow get silicone I can't
remember the years but they did remember
when they banned silicone for a while
because it wasn't it wasn't uh it was
banned because it was not it was
unhealthy and I I remember thinking of
myself I'm like oh that's stupid
somebody obviously won in some like
money War battle like yeah I don't know
I just remember people saying silicone
was softer and I wanted really natural
and even though I was like healthy
minded at the time not like I am today
um it was still a bad aesthetic for me
so I was just like I don't care if
saline safer I want I want him to feel
real did you even know silicone to be
unsafe I knew there were risks I knew
that there if if it if they leaked into
your body that you could have some toxic
reaction and you didn't want them to
leak and that's why this is is like the
basic due diligence that I did
um silicone has more risk than saline
because if somehow they leaked which is
very unlikely it could be toxic to your
body but you would know and then you
could get them removed and it wouldn't
be like tragic I didn't realize until I
just took them out that I got like the
silicone gel like they had and maybe
this was after it was banned and then
they came back with this gel that was
less likely to leak so I knew there was
like this 10-year expiry but then I also
knew people that had their implants in
for 20 years I was like skirt by for a
couple years you're gonna be fine then I
had a child and then I breastfed and
thank God I was still able to breastfeed
that was my biggest worry but after you
breastfeed you lose a lot of tissue so
then I started to feel in the last
couple years I started to feel the
implants in me even though they're small
but I had I could feel and I was like
okay I gotta get them out and then I saw
your your story and your and I was like
okay I'm ready to do this let's do this
good job listening to your intuition
um because I feel like it does have to
resonate so let's go back to let's go
back to a couple of Concepts here you
want it to feel like more of a woman
and you wanted to be proportionate so
what does woman mean why do we have an
image of woman a certain way and what is
proportions even where do we get that
idea like let's unpack like this the I
the the driving force behind it that not
only you but like so many others me too
I mean I remember afterwards I was like
oh I mean I even said it in the
interview last night I was like I don't
have to buy anything new other than bras
I was like sports bras still fit clothes
still fit I just felt like I was
obviously more proportionate and I would
like fit my body so let's talk about
like first woman just explain when you
said I want to feel like more like a
woman were there was there a look or was
it like scenarios was it with a guy like
what what a woman mean yeah I mean I
think I grew up in the Victoria's Secret
age you know we had I've I I was born in
1979 so in the 80s and early 90s it was
like the supermodels were all kind of
Victoria's Secret models that's song
have you heard that song the Victoria's
Secret Song I don't think so oh my God
you have to hear the Victoria's Secret
song it's basically saying Victoria was
made up by a dude dude in Ohio Les
Waxman is made up by a dude in Ohio
there she's not real and I was like oh
my God that's so true so true
true exactly so it's this unrealistic I
ideal of the woman that you know every
guy
you know and Playboy that kind of pin up
proportion never appealed to me but like
the bikini model svelte but still curvy
some of it was natural some of it was
not many much of it was airbrushed so
again unrealistic and that was just what
I grew up thinking was the ideal for men
you know and then when you are in your
late 20s early 30s and
you know things aren't working out in
love or acting you just like want to
make a change and you're like well this
is the problem this is the one area I'm
not proportionate you know or whatever
it's it's so silly to look back on now
but
but at the same time like I have a I
have a relative who is six foot two and
female and she's always been super
skinny
super tall
um she's been happily married for many
years to a man much shorter than her but
she's just always been self-conscious
about her body and recently she got
implants and it's like brought her out
of her shell so like
I don't know like again it's
the reason she was in a shells because
she's comparing herself to some
unrealistic ideal but at the same time
it's like
they've done so much good for her until
they don't so okay the underlying
problem being not feeling like woman not
proportionate not being not being tall
but not having you know boobs or
whatever it was and helping her feel
feel the same way womanly proportionate
is that the answer do you think like I
guess what I'm saying is when I got them
I wanted to feel more womanly as well
and when I like when a guy grabs it
there ain't nothing there okay and then
I was like ah and then they felt him and
I was like oh my God now I just think
about the fact that they're fake like it
didn't even work and you know then they
they come out and I still feel you still
have reasons for to feel insecure if
it's not my boobs it's my butt if it's
not my butt it's my abs if it's on my
abs it's my legs like it just found
another place to be unhappy I I mean
that's what I found so you know like
systemically I feel like it's more of a
root cause so do you feel like it solved
your problems or do you feel like it
just transferred a hundred apprentices
transfers you know and it's and and this
is the journey that I'm on this is a
journey I think we all are on is to to
get to a place where we can fully accept
every aspect of ourselves and our psyche
and now I mean I love having them out
like you said like you wanted
you wanted to be more womanly and
proportionate but then when there was
actual intimacy and interaction with
them you're like
I'm saying you know and I've like made
sure I did like the doctor like after
you get implants in you're supposed to
like move them so they don't get hard
and get encapsulated and so I did like
twice as much I was like forget
something like I'm making these girls
natural you know but you're still
self-conscious when with intimacy
because you're like there's and you're
like there's gonna be a little bit of a
because you know they're not real again
it's a journey it's where you are and
I'm so I I heard your story and you were
immediately felt clearer and a lot of
your symptoms went away just removing
them from your body
but energetically too I just feel like
lighter and more myself however I have
because I did a lift because I could be
breastfeeding or hanging real low so I
did like a little lift so I had this
vertical scar now and you just looking
I'm just looking in the mirror and
they're I'm like so happy with them out
and I'm so happy with them being small
and perky but now I have a scar that's
just like oh God the brutality that we
put ourselves through is so nuts it's
true okay well let's talk about the
surgery itself because I know that there
was like a pretty big Discovery in
getting them out so you know you decided
to to get them out it was time I think
we talked about it it energetic maybe
share if there was symptoms or not and
just kind of like what ended up kind of
tipping the scales for you there was
never any acute symptoms that I think
that you were experiencing but again we
adapt to so much like Lord knows where
my brain fog came from or just normal
things that I I normalized in life
um not there's a million symptoms that
could have been attributed to them I had
gotten I'd never gotten a mammogram in
my life
um for some reason they just never
appealed to me and then I researched
them and the effective to risk wasn't
didn't resonate with me so luckily I
found this guy who has this really
amazing
um it's called sonosine Dr Kevin Kelly
out of Pasadena he just retired but he's
taught other people in this technology
so it's a
really high-tech ultrasound that can
detect early cancers much more effective
than and safe non um no radiation than a
mammogram so I'd been going to him for a
few years and so I went to one of his
colleagues and she was like you know I
think
that there's some ruptures in the right
one
and
she said but they weren't major but she
was like they detected some rupturing
and she's like I think I really think
that you should consider removing these
like it's 12 years I yeah this one's got
ruptures and I was like that's
interesting and I had noticed and I
don't know when it started so I keep
grabbing my bits
um but when I maybe drink covet or maybe
it was from breastfeeding but when I
started lying down a couple years ago
the right one would like the left one
would fall naturally and the right one
would kind of just chill when I felt
them they were soft but then when I laid
down it was felt like encapsulated like
it stuck maybe it was stuck to the stuck
to the the rib cage or something like
that yeah and it was weird because I
would be lying there and like ones here
and one's just so that felt odd um and
then when she said there was ruptures I
was like oh that makes sense so I just
and then you were telling your story I
was like oh I need to get these out I'm
ready it was this just kind of turn of
events where my girlfriend told me about
this doctor in New York and I happened
to be New York and
I went to see him and I thought I was
going to see like about like some
natural Botox because that's about as
much as I do he was like no I'm a neck
down surgeon I do a lot of like mommy
makeover stuff I was like why am I here
you know because she does he did her
Botox but only a few people and and I
was like oh while I'm here I want to get
my implants out I didn't do I just
trusted that I was there for a reason he
got me in relatively quickly
um you know after a month of like pre-op
checkouts and all that stuff and
um it all went from there but what he
discovered as he opened me up uh is that
this one had fully ruptured the right
one and we actually did it near
Halloween and he posted it on his thing
it was like yellow like when you sent me
pictures of that I was like I think to
myself truly I drove 200 miles an hour
and hit walls and I literally had one
checked in an MRI
like in 2018 because it was hard and I
thought maybe it's ruptured and
everything was fine so I'm like how does
this happen like how does the silicone
just sort of like
fail as we know transdermal works so
like your scar tissue is still seeping
and leaching like there's no way it's
not a it's not concrete you know so
that's uh did the doctor say that that
was a really dangerous situation he was
basically just like I haven't seen this
in five years and then you know I was
grateful that my body encapsulated it
but like you said you know there's still
stuff that's happening you know and I
don't I didn't even ask him about mold
you know what what was going on there if
it's if it's ruptured like Lord knows
what's seeping through my body so I
definitely want to do
um some sort of like detox and cleansing
protocol just do some testing then that
way you know I mean sometimes people
test things and they're totally fine and
that hopefully is the case but yeah
those tests are really easy it was a
godsend and I don't know how my body did
it and my body protected me my body is
so intelligent but Lord knows how that
thing ruptured I mean what like was it
the pressure of bread the breast milk I
don't I don't know what have you noticed
after have you noticed anything or or is
it more just like uh you know what what
have you enjoyed about it if you like
symptom-wise I'm curious but then also
just like energetically you know where
were you at and what were you feeling
needed to shift and then what are the
little things that you notice now that
you're like oh my God that's great yeah
I just feel
there's just like a lightness of being
and a back to myself so
it's just a lighter load and you know
I've had like upper right shoulder neck
problems which is the side that had
ruptured
um so I think there was a lot of like
muscle tension that was also like
protecting me too so that I think is
going to be able to release more and
more which and that's been just chronic
for years you know probably
enhanced by the implant so
um I mean that alone is a game changer
of quality of life because that's it's a
constant like I feel like I have a bag
of rocks on my on my back so I think
that that is all able to unwind and
and I just feel like I don't know I just
feel like I can open my heart more you
know even again like you want to be more
proportionate you want to be more
womanly but then you subconsciously know
that there's some inauthenticity here so
you kind of like hunch you kind of you
don't you know you don't at least I
didn't I was a little bit like
protective too of being too womanly you
know it's like you can never hit it just
right so uh just having that whole
narrative and whole thing gone
and it's a journey I don't like beat
myself up I don't it's like that's where
I was at 12 years ago here I am today
and and I also think it's so interesting
too as we see
there's just different I think it's just
like also
not to name any like celebrity families
or anything but like a lot of people are
getting butt implants and boobs and lips
and can you imagine sitting on implants
I mean I'd lay down in yoga or for a
massage and I'd lay down and I'd be like
ah these things are annoying and they
were 200 CC's can you imagine sitting
your ass down with ass implants I just
can't I can't I've just always thought
the goal was to get a smaller ass I
agreed I going to the gym and I'm like I
don't want a bigger butt okay I don't I
don't want a bigger butt so hamstrings
it is but there's a whole culture that
likes a bigger butt and those women
thought that that was more womanly you
know I just I don't know I don't know so
Barbie proportions not to call anyone
out that there was a picture of like
Barbie and someone and like how the body
was shaped the same and I'm like it's
not [ __ ] real but I think that
there's an unwinding of that now too and
people are going back to a more I don't
know this certainly feels right for me
and I'm just also at a different place
in my life where I'm more about who am I
authentically and less searching for any
sort of feedback or validation from the
outside world and more just like what
makes me feel good what do I want to
express
you know and it took me 43 years to get
to this point
um and you have to just go along the way
so that was just part of the journey
talk about the work that got you there
because you know when we talked before
about this you know energetically you
just said I'm just not there anymore
like I just don't care and it doesn't
match my idea of health and well-being
and the things that I stand for and
believe in and like I've just moved on
past that needing that so like what was
the work that you've done like what have
been the most significant things you've
done that have got you to a place where
you could confidently take them out and
be glad like that's the that's the
feeling I get from you is you're like
super thrilled I'm super thrilled and
there's a point in time when we wouldn't
have been and we wanted them and there's
a place where people have them that
should be getting them out that's scared
that they won't look okay and so talk
about that work because you are you know
just one of my dear friends that really
does the work and I'm curious what that
is because for people listening
um you know I think they'll be really
helpful
yeah
um it's constant work and it's constant
changing and I'm like going back and and
reading things that I read 10 years ago
that changed my life I'm reading the
untethered Soul oh yeah I'm reading it
now as if I'm reading it for the first
time and I'm just like oh my gosh like
this is the gateway to freedom and even
like Return To Love which Marianne
Williamson wrote and that was like my
first
one of my first massive like openings to
my spiritual journey when I was 19 years
old someone in Australia gave me the
book and I read it on the airplane home
and I was like oh my gosh this is
everything gateway to love return to
love so untethered Soul Return To Love
which of course it's so beautiful to
reread them because as sad Guru told me
you know like when I was interviewing
him about his book Karma he's like every
time you read this it'll be a different
book because basically when we change
the things we see change like that's
just how it goes so amazing and I love
that Michael Beckwith is one of my
biggest spiritual teachers and I'm
actually going to be on his podcast
later today
um which is full circle and wild you
know he talks about like he's just a
Channeler of spirit and he'll read you
know books about all the Masters and use
them in his sermons and teachings and
he'll he'll have like some sort of
divine channeling and he'll be like I
read this book this passage in this book
and then he goes that morning and he
just like
pontificates about it and and just gives
us fire and then he goes back to find
that passage and it just it was never
even there
right because his interpretation of it
was being like orchestrated by some
perception and then when you go to find
it the words are not basically arranged
the same or like you aren't arranged the
same so the words aren't the same
correct correct and and there's one
thing that I think Deepak told me but I
think was an ancient
saying but it's
a man can never step into the same river
twice because it's not the same man and
it's not the same river
so I just I just feel like all of the
work I've done is just it's constant
um it has to be for me because even if
I'm like constantly doing the work I
mean I'm raising it I'm trying to doing
my best to raise a three and a half year
old child so I'm trying to like learn
about conscience parenting which is
really all about re-parenting myself
because our parents didn't really have
the tools to parent us consciously so
and then at the same time I'm like
interacting with my parents and the
other night like I exploded at my dad
and I felt like so therapeutic for
finally getting so much off my chest in
a late night post stress burnt out
manner it was not conscious at all
um and my poor dad was like devastated
and hurt and I felt like finally I've
Unleashed this you know
this might use my voice right of all
this pent-up frustration of years and I
felt like fantastic and then he's just
you know devastated and hurt so then we
had a nice beautiful healing
conversation the next day such a nice
Catalyst though you know yeah yeah and
but it's like life is going to continue
to just throw us triggers until we all
the stuff comes up to the surface and I
feel like collectively
we are in such a pressure cooker right
now that we we need to lean into the
work because all like the FR I just it
has to be a frequency thing you know we
started to learn about like how the
frequency of or the Earth negative field
like was changing in 2012 human
resonance yes and and I'm feeling that
and I'm feeling that the world is
feeling that and I'm feeling that
there's been certain
catalysts like Trump and others who are
inciting all this [ __ ] that's been under
the rug and in our shadows and and it's
just all coming up to the surface to be
seen to be healed to be dealt with and
it's gnarly and it's chaotic and it's
really overwhelming for people and it's
heartbreaking
that just we don't have the tools to
manage it so like even I have I feel
like I have so much tools and I've been
doing the work for so long and I'm still
freaking overwhelmed and just like
holding on for dear life right now what
is your perspective of it do you feel
like it's the best of the worst time
ever do you feel like this is the best
thing that ever happened or worst thing
that ever happened like the last few
years have just been
well a lot in a lot of ways but there's
been so much Duality there's been like
you know things being brought to light
but then there's also like so much
Darkness being seen so like how do you
choose to where do you put your energy
well I get emotionally hooked and I'm
like this is the like darkest time I
think hang on back up because I think
this would be really valuable because
you and I are a little different in the
way that we feel energy and and what we
feel so like maybe explain because I
think this is also enlightening for
people to understand how empathy and
transference of of energy works with
people so you know how are you feeling
it and what do other people feel because
I know you've gone down into this you
know understand all this so explain to
people because there's a lot of
different people out there what I'm
feeling is like
like I'm watching a very bad movie and
I'm feeling and I'm trying to pull back
and like be an observer and not get
too sucked in by the movie because
that's when we feel helpless and
hopeless
um
and I but I also feel as I'm able to
like step back and observe
I mean again I feel like we're in this
big drama and that's part of being a
human you know that's part of this human
experience of being in these flesh suits
um we're Spiritual Beings having a
physical experience and this time in
history this which again if we're gonna
get into that deep talk it's like time
is not linear you know like so there's
like
holographic parallel
Dimensions
uses yes uses exactly so
you know I I have to try and stay in
that mindset but when I get hooked into
the the drama what I'm seeing is like
kind of
all the things that have been
defining Beauty and what it means to be
a woman all of these type things
um greed
patriarchy all of these things that have
been in power and control for so long
they're just they're breaking down
because again as frequency and energy is
rising there's just a new paradigm
that's being called for
um and there's a rebalancing you know
and and I don't know like some people
say like we have 60 harvests left before
the next Extinction you know and maybe
that's true I don't I don't know any of
that stuff I just know that like
you know on the human level this
person that I don't know personally
um the guy twitch sir twitch a lot he
was Ellen's DJ I like followed him and
his family randomly during covid they've
got three point something million
followers and it was just these this
cute couple that like choreographed
these dances with their adorable kids
seemingly the most joyful person on the
planet just committed suicide a couple
days ago and I was like
it just brings me back to the human
element of compassion like you could
have everything and life is so gnarly
and overwhelming right now from a
certain perspective
that you're just heart your heart breaks
for people I mean I had the flu two days
ago and and I hate the flu I haven't had
the flu for in a decade or so
and my body felt like I got hit by a
truck
you know it was brutal and
I have the resources and the privilege
to call someone to come give me an IV I
have an amazing doctor who like is you
know I have I was prepared with all the
holistic things I battle like I started
on it all right away I'm taking like
baking soda and epsom salt baths I have
the luxury of a nanny who even though
she wasn't booked like lives 20 minutes
away and said I'll come in and I'll
sleep with your child so you can rest
like I have the luxury I'm like I feel
so shitty I'm so tired for people that
can't afford help or don't have anyone
to help they have to work they have to
survive and battle the flu or battle
chronic illness like when that like it
just gave me such compassion for the
world like I don't know how people are
surviving right now I have all the
support in the world and it was a
[ __ ] struggle for me you know so
I just go I oscillate through this like
observation of just like okay we're in
this massive drama right now and this is
great fodder for growth and
transformation and like getting me
aligned with what my work here is on the
planet
and then I get pulled into this just
like [ __ ] dude it's hard for people you
feel so deeply like it's one of the most
beautiful things about you is how you
are able to really understand the pain
that people are going through
um
you know your empathy is
off the charts in so many great ways but
it's overwhelming to you and so like I
just want to give you a hug because like
I know how I know how heavy that all
feels and it's part of your work too and
why you made the documentary heal which
is how we ended up meeting because I saw
it and why you do the podcast and why
you why you do so many things to try and
just get people to wake up to themselves
to the world to other options other ways
of thinking so
like if you know what what's the remedy
what's the remedy for a situation like
twitch what I we don't know his story
all looked like is that he was super
happy and dancing and had kids in a
family like
what is the remedy for situations like
that where someone is essentially so
alone in their experience like what can
we do and what does culture need to
welcome in and Usher in so that that is
not the result from that we that were
that we witness
yeah I mean for me what I'm feeling the
remedy is is like right now I feel like
anything that causes pressure you know
they had such a like
I mean he had a successful career and
then coveted and then he and his wife
had this like successful Instagram and
God I can't even speak to him I should
just even stop speaking because I have
no idea what was going on behind behind
closed doors but I just know that with
social media and instantaneous
information overload like there's just
this pressure to do we're seeing other
people be so productive this money likes
this many followers these Partnerships
making money whatever it is and we feel
that's available to us and then we feel
like failures when we can't do it like
there's just too much pressure on us
right now
I think they're like the what I'm
craving is like like this flu actually
kick-started
I'm really craving just like a detox and
a cleanse and like a and and this is
kind of what nature intends us to do
every winter
is it is a cocooning you know a quieting
it's like the winter solstice it's dark
it wants you to like just be in your
cozy home be with yourself be with
Solitude and and and and
reconnect with who you are and and get
you prepared for the year to come
and that's my remedy is just it's just
like disconnecting a little bit from the
pressures of the social media from the
information overload and I do feel like
eventually kind of like how
this you know
a lot of people are are getting explant
surgery and a lot of people are are
being more natural and authentic a lot
of people are moving
um and buying farms and growing their
own food and getting creating their own
local communities
um I do think that there is going to be
a correction of this digital addiction
that's killing so many of us
um and we're gonna disconnect and
reconnect to Nature and reconnect to
each other
so I think that's a massive part of the
remedy that's going to happen naturally
as a natural Evolution
um but individually I think that we all
need to
just
remove that pressure by disconnecting
reconnecting to ourselves reconnecting
to Nature
and then the other and then like really
the other part of it the work that I'm
doing right now through untethering of
the soul and all these you know other
books that I'm reading like is just
learning how to fully accept ourselves
and the shadow parts of ourselves
because I find that this cancel culture
and this polarization that's happening
because of social media and because of
this political climate and a broken
system of our government
um that we live in fear of making a
mistake or saying the wrong thing and
getting canceled it's like
yeah there's mistakes that need
consequences for sure that are just
horrific and can't existence in a
healthy Society but then there's
mistakes and things that people do and
and like we have to be allowed to make
mistakes and we have to understand that
everybody's human and like
you cannot condemn and yell and hate and
whether on social media or or not like
nobody's perfect we're all human we've
all made mistakes and we're not allowing
when we're condemning someone else it's
because we're really condemning that
part of ourselves that we haven't
accepted yet that's down there that
we're just like pushing down and denying
and spending a lot of energy and getting
depressed and anxious and burnt out
because of
so I think that's the remedy is really
looking to the parts of ourselves like
using triggers
to as Flags to go oh that's a part of me
that I haven't accepted yet or that's a
wound that I have that I haven't healed
yet
and so using anything any person in our
family any situation in the world using
it as feedback so that we can turn to
the part of ourselves that we're
condemning denying rejecting or haven't
looked at because it was a painful wound
that we haven't that happened years ago
that we haven't addressed
so true so true it's always an inside
job and our reality is just showing us
us the whole time because you might
react to something at something going on
in the world where it doesn't it doesn't
register for me it's not a wound it's
not something I think about and vice
versa so what's the process of that work
because for the people listening whether
it's you know
um being triggered by you know looks and
appearance of people on social and it
reflecting on like all they're thinking
is like they think something negative or
negative about themselves or whether
it's a relationship and somebody does
something you don't agree with it like
there's so much what what is it that is
creating so much Division and judgment
and then what's the process like what's
that process look like when something
comes up for you as a trigger what do
you do
great question still trying to figure
that out myself
I try to breathe in the untethered Soul
we're it's talking about like
rather than getting hooked by the psyche
because we're trying to get our mind
to control like
the outside circumstances I don't know
he puts it so much more eloquently those
protecting us like we have patterns that
establish as in childhood and they're
irrational as we get older because we
don't need the same things we needed
like we're going to have food we're
going to have shelter hopefully or or
generally speaking we're lucky enough to
be in that situation so like things
aren't actually a threat but we still re
we still bounce back to the original
wound when it was a threat so things are
things are not accurately judged as we
get older and so our ego's job is just
protect protect protect make sure that
we don't get exposed to something that
would hurt us deeply like it did the
first time and so it just that's all it
does but it's only thinking about right
now it's not thinking about next year
it's not thinking about 10 years from
now so the ego wants to be satisfied
like immediately to protect you and it
just doesn't have the long game in mind
so we just flip out on things because
that's that's because right now that is
the best solution to negate against that
original wound exactly
and the simplest the simplest uh I guess
exercise and and again it might take
many many times of practicing to then
diminish one Trigger or one wound
um one wounding so is is to realize that
we are we are not our thoughts we are
not our mind we are the Observer we are
the Consciousness the soul the
um
The Observer we can we can sit back and
observe our neurotic thoughts and mind
and emotions and so we are the Observer
we are not our thoughts so when we get
hooked by a thought when we get mad at
someone for betraying us or
um or if we feel this emotion in our
heart that starts tightening and you
know that should like once we start to
practice awareness we go oh there's a
change here oh there's a trigger and
then we start to pull back and go what
is it rather than get hooked by it and
then we're in the drama and then we want
to kill the person and or you know we
want to be the victim woe is me and so
it's just starting to tune in like oh
when I start to feel the constriction
when I start to hold my breath when I
start to get angry
wow okay something's happening here and
and step back and observe and the more
you probably you know sometimes it'll
come after
20 minutes of being in it that's the
that's what I always ask people I'm like
okay I love the Observer it's great and
all except for it's the triggers are
still real and like how do I not get
caught in the trigger in that moment
like what is the actual access point
that or like corrects this pattern of
being triggered it's it's very nuanced
and tough
different ones are gonna hook you for
yeah before you go I don't want to feel
this way anymore you know and the more
you can then go
you know I don't want to feel this way
anymore and you start to just you pull
back and You observe and you start to
explore like where is this coming from
or this is what I'm trying to do like
you know like oh I'm so angry at my dad
and then and then I'm starting to
realize why is it so hard for me to
apologize why is that so uncomfortable
for me you know and then observing that
and then say okay what's more important
for me to be right or to be
loving you know to be right or to have a
relationship with my father sorry I
always bring my dad into the support guy
mine too I always bring my dad into it's
usually but now my mom gets in there too
and I'm like oh [ __ ] sorry Mom and Dad
like that's part of my it's part of my
story I know it's part of all of our
stories every parent will make everybody
you're either gonna love her you're
gonna love a kid too much or too little
it's like you can't get it right and
it's part of the Journey of Being Human
there's just a certain amount of trials
tribulations and suffering that's I
think in is just um part of Being Human
so and it's made us who we are and
that's part of of it it's like you know
the goal the goal is to be free of the
suffering the free of the the the
triggers hooking us and and pulling us
into the drama the the more freedom and
expansion we have despite what's
happening around us because there's so
much out of our control
then we have a little bit more like
lightness of being and
um freedom in life to you know not get
hooked by all the minutia that's
happening in the world
um and then to be able to stand in an
expanded space and lend people a hand or
you know go on adventures and do things
we were put on Earth to do
um so it's just it's it's such a
priority for me that I want to practice
it every day and some days I fail
miserably because I haven't slept I'm
not eating well I'm drinking too much
whatever it is it all interacts like
when my vessel like I just had the flu
for two days you know which detox my
body in every way couldn't eat you know
and
then now I'm feeling Crystal Clear I've
rested thank God I was able to rest and
now my vessel is like clear strong it
was like a reset button but if so I have
a little bit more space to show up in
the world and like do the work you know
but when I'm burnt out when I'm stressed
out when I'm not eating right when I'm
not when my physical vessel is not
optimally running it's way harder to
mentally and emotionally like
step back and observe it's just you get
hooked and that's the other thing it's
like we've got to prioritize taking care
of our vessel so that we can show up
spiritually and do the work right why do
you think it's so hard for so many of us
to take care of ourselves first and stay
in Integrity why is it that why is that
so difficult
again roles that we've been programmed
with in society
um you know I
sometimes put even if I'm like
burnt out whatever I put my partner's
needs first because he's the you know
he's making money so I've always like
put my work second my well-being second
um you know and I'm starting to take a
little bit more ownership of like I can
show up much more
powerfully for my family if I put my
needs first I've been I've started to
like
realize how important that is
um and I'm observing it and other people
around me as they're starting to like
establish new boundaries because they're
realizing that because you have
boundaries you're teaching people how to
take care of you
by showing them how you take care of
yourself yes respectfully modeling for
my daughter that we mothers women
anyone male female anyone like if you
you have to prioritize not at the
expense obviously the child's needs are
first and foremost at all times but for
her to witness me saying I really need
to to go meditate right now or Mom I
need to I need to work out I need to
move my body I need to like
flesh out some frustration whatever it
is like she's now going oh these things
are important you know and of course
it's a balance
um her needs are a priority but uh she
sees she sees that I take care of myself
and I and I explain to her why I need to
do that so
um I'm getting better at it but again
programming societal roles you know in
the home it's like just moms are and
women in general are just
I don't know they're just there's more
demanded from them on the nurturing side
and then like I'm sick and I'm like
but you're like what nobody cares about
me what's happening you know what about
this uh I found something that's really
helpful is this sort of forgiveness is
forgiveness to yourself like the self I
mean we were we were sort of talking
about that of interesting things that we
could talk about and forgiveness is one
of those things that came up so you know
um why it why is it so hard to forgive
ourselves and why do we not even know
that we need to like I think that's even
a thing like I don't know do I need to
forgive myself for anything and and
there's such power in that you know have
you realized that there's anything you
need to forgive yourself for and what
was the what was what what was the
feeling why when what happened after I
just think that like I mean every day if
I make a Mis like if I feel like I'm not
if I'm again not taking care of myself
and that I'm short with my daughter I'm
gonna lose my temper with my daughter or
blow up at my dad like these little
things we need to forgive ourselves for
we can't
me like I want to be perfect you know
I've I've even just what's coming to
mind is like growing up as an actor you
audition for something and you fail so
many times you get rejected Time After
Time After Time and
I didn't forgive myself in those moments
I rejected myself I beat myself up I
criticized myself I'm like you're you
know I've put in so much effort and I'm
getting so little return and I'm like oh
I'm a failure I'm wasting my 20s like
I'm not forgiving I I needed to forgive
myself in those moments I needed to
realize that like
so it's it's an energy of like releasing
the pressure off the valve and then you
show up in the world a lot more
confident present loose and people then
want to hire you whether you're an actor
or a plumber or anything else it's like
when we're so
punishing ourselves over and over for
little things that don't even matter to
the rest of the world of course bigger
things when you hurt someone or you
again because you haven't taken care of
yourself so you've reacted to something
you've let a trigger get the best of you
or you make a mistake you make bad
judgments
um you know
I just feel like we need to be given
we need to be taught how to forgive
ourselves and how important it is and I
feel like that's why we are in the state
we are today of this cancel culture
because we beat ourselves up so much and
we hold ourselves to this impossible
standard that
like we have to
beat other people up and condemn other
people because again there's this like
pressure valve of all these things we're
stuffing down that we haven't accepted
and we've been
hiding because we're so ashamed and we
haven't forgiven ourselves even though
again in the grand scheme of things
they're little things or the things that
we thought were so massive in childhood
um that were so devastating and
life-changing it was like not a big
thing but it held it down
turn the valve long enough those things
Fester those things get moldy those
things get compounded and so all of that
to say I think we need to learn to
forgive ourselves in the moment so that
we don't suppress so much shame and
guilt and and as we learn to do that to
ourselves I think we're going to live
and see and experience a much more
forgiving not cancer cultury
society and reality we're treating
ourselves that way which inevitably
means we treat others that way like what
we judge in ourselves we judge in others
so forgiveness for ourself is is the way
to start with it and I think that would
be a really powerful tool to transform
so many things going on
um I mean you know let's talk a little
bit about like masculine feminine I feel
like I'm always on this topic I'm very
curious about that you know we're
talking about forgiveness like you know
there's some I interview a lot of guys
these days and I'm really curious about
this patriarchy sort of theme I'm
curious about the masculine feminine
like I'm thinking do we forgive men for
being in power like what does that look
like and how how do we how do we forgive
ourselves for not standing I mean
there's also an equal and opposite like
we should forgive ourselves for not
standing up for ourselves in the past
right so what it what needs to come into
balance the masculine the me I'm just
going to use man and woman from the male
side and the female side what do you
think needs to be rectified because
again when we're turning the turning the
fingers back on ourselves as the the way
that things move forward and we are
talking about forgiveness another one is
unite I think another powerful tool to
balancing things out is this uniting of
the masculine and feminine within us so
what do you think is out of balance when
we're looking at generally speaking men
and women in society the systems and for
like just the systems of society are out
of balance because they are very
masculine leaning in what way like in
the way that they and who runs them or
like how it is run both both I think
greed and capitalism and is very like a
masculine
um at the expense of I mean maybe it's
not but I think it is like at the
expense of
the Earth and resources and maybe life
like human life and in getting a product
made and increasing profit margins and
you know enslaving children or raping
the Earth if it's minerals or you know
releasing lots of toxic stuff into the
air or into our food and all this stuff
I feel like that's not a feminine thing
to do not a nurturing thing to do
um so I think just like
there's a lot I mean there's obviously
so much I'm grateful for about
capitalism but then the imbalances that
were
the greed and the
um
lobbying that happens and
the buying of politicians and then they
have to keep up like I mean that's a
whole rabbit hole we got to go down but
so I think I think the the the
domination of men in power that's
obviously been enabled by A system that
is
created by men in power for I don't know
when that started it's been eons right
feel that the new paradigm is like we
need to go back to that
no there's a re-naturing that has to
happen the the masculine
patriarchy driven
um
system that we're living in has
disconnected us from nature and it's
called Mother Nature because it's
feminine like so we are genetically
modifying our food we are genetically
modifying our
DNA at this point we are
um
we are in addicted to screens and not
out in nature like we're we're
denaturing ourselves our food and our
our and and then we're raping our planet
so we're denaturing nature
um so I think that part of the big
rebalancing is bringing that feminine
um approach and nurturing and love and
holistic
um realizing that everything's involved
we can't it's conscientiousness a
conscientiousness and a and a connection
to Nature and each other that's missing
right now because of this kind of
masculine profit at all costs Bottom
Dollar Bottom Dollar we've been
denatured
um by greed and Industry
um and this pressure and we're seeing it
in social media again
um like when at all costs get followers
at all costs and so now I think there's
going to be
um you know more females coming into
Power into the current system before the
system can change and then also just a
as as individually we become more
balanced doing the work of feminine and
masculine doing the Forgiveness work
um accepting ourselves
taking out our implants whatever it is
um you know then we'll see collectively
you know again I just love this idea of
like being more local being more in
community and and just that's that just
feels more feminine and connected what
do you think a woman's superpower is I
know that one of them is bringing a
freaking life into this world that's not
for every everybody but we are like a
portal for life that's crazy actually
yeah I did an interview and somebody was
like well the most straightforward
portals like the portal that you can
create like you can create is like a
child a child's a portal and I was like
oh my God totally I think love our
capacity to love and feel when [ __ ] goes
down lift a car off of a child like the
the we all have that maternal Instinct
whether you have children or not we we
feel this it's it's our love I think our
superpower is love and
I mean you are so like you came in with
so many gifts and you love
racing you know you loved competing you
but like your love for it drove you like
your love for
your curiosity is a version of love you
know like you're we're just I think our
superpower is love I think that
um we love our children we love our
friends we love our girlfriends we love
our husbands we love our
wives we love we just love so greatly
and that cause that allows us to do very
powerful things what is it that a man
needs to respect about a woman and what
is it a woman needs to respect about a
man that's challenged right now that
would bring us closer together
man I think that men
need to respect women's intelligence
more because I just feel like we have a
subtle intelligence
like intuition like intuition abilities
and empathy
that
will make us
I think some of the best leaders in the
world and I think we're starting to get
that shot where we haven't in history as
much but I think the intelligence that
women have
is a much more complex intelligence the
different intelligence different
intelligence intelligence and I think
that it can complement complement the
intelligence and and what what men have
been able to create
um but it's a different intelligence and
it's time for that intelligence to step
forward a little bit more so if men the
smartest men will recognize that and tap
into that all right now you got to flip
it you gotta I'm like a really like I
have so much Libra in me I'm like well
there's the man but there's the woman
like if we're going to talk about the
picture everybody talking about
matriarchy so what is it that we need to
respect and honor about men that is
challenged right now that they do really
well what's coming up for me is their
ability to survive like when [ __ ] goes
down they step up I mean I know the men
in my life too and that is what I
respect and admire again I'm getting
emotional why am I getting emotional I
just feel like times are freaking tough
right now and what I see with the men in
my life is they just they don't sit
around
they're not soft you know they're just
like I'm gonna [ __ ] figure it out
excuse my French there's some French
that needs to happen right now because
times are tough for everybody and
and it's all relative but like the
reason men are in power is because the
burden's been on them to survive and
keep the keep the the family unit
protected in the wild that's still in
them and that's
thank God for men in that way you know
and and again just like you said like we
have these wounds as children
um that no longer are irrational at this
point because we're bigger and more
independent and can fend for ourselves
so we can let those go and and
Nature has changed like we live in these
cities we're not fighting saber-toothed
tigers and and warring tribes but
there's still that instinct to survive
and and that's to be honored and
respected and and I'm grateful for that
you know so it's kind of almost within
what we need to love honor and respect
about men categorically speaking
masculine energy that is part of the
problem it's the fact that let's say you
need to survive so you need to go slay
the dragon get the meat build the house
make the money is what's actually gotten
out of control that's
and that it's come at the expense of too
many other things now and so I love
because I know this is so I think this
is what you're moving into is more
around
um Mother Earth and like regenerative
and what can we do to sort of connect
back with nature again is that when we
think about when we Orient ourselves
with what is best for the planet what is
best for longevity what is best for
keeping things the you know alive and
well you you when we all do that we
Orient back to intuition taking care
nurturing
making different decisions from a
conscientious standpoint about business
look I think of money as Just Energy and
it's just energy and like if one
institution or Paradigm Falls another is
gonna rise like it's just an energy and
like we think of money as this sort of
be-all end and all but like skill and
trade is going to be pretty freaking
important when institutions of money
collapse and there isn't anything in
your bank anymore so like there is a
need for all of it and and it's just you
know you won't need 100 Grand in the
bank when you just need to like build a
fire so
you know we need to get back to like
back to square one back to back to
looking after longevity and nature and
our nature in a more caring way
and that's exactly what's gotten out of
balance is that like drive to survive
and then you do so well that you're like
oh but I don't want to lose what I have
and so this is this like masculinity
toxic masculinity on a hamster wheel
that's gotten out of control and that's
where we are now
um and so as we
as we like more of this feminine
leadership comes into power and and and
more men are able to
um
just it's it's almost like
women are in charge of taking care of
the village and the family so as we
teach kind of the younger generations of
men to then go okay we only Thrive when
the community The Village thrives so
we've been so
um
everybody's been so individualized and
the politicians it's like they started
out with altruistic and a lot of them
still have it altruistic ideals and
that's why they got into this thankless
job of politics but then they got a
little self-interest perks along the way
and then it's grown into the snowball
and they're believing their own lies to
continue to survive because that's what
they feel they need to survive we're
driven by fear you know yeah well when
we talk about survival what's like
becoming a little bit more clear in the
spirit of this discussion about getting
your implants out is that like if the
service if the surviving is Donald
Hoffman I interviewed him he's a
brilliant guy and it's like he believes
that base reality is just Consciousness
and that essentially our purpose is to
survive like Fitness is what he calls it
so now imagine that you're in now
imagine that you're in your your you're
in the days of huts and getting the
slaying the the deer for dinner or
whatever it is and like you survival of
the species and of of you in some
extended way also means having children
which means being chosen by a man to do
that so as time goes somewhat of
survival has been well if I want to be
chosen I need to look right I need to be
attractive to the male I need them to
want me because children is what keeps
things going like survival and fitness
is is rooted there so here we are now
doing all kinds of things which again we
might be looking at men and saying
you're going and destructing the planet
because you're short-sighted you have no
conscientiousness you you don't care
about what's going on with our soil you
don't care about our oceans but then
here we are as women going I'm going to
stick a bunch of foreign [ __ ] inside of
me because my survival is short-sighted
and I go I need C's at least so that
someone will like me so that I have
Fitness and survival for life to be
chosen so that I can bear children so
that my genetics continue so the planet
continues so we're not all that idea
about this man who's raping the planet
protect me or whatever you know like
exactly you know we're not protecting
ourselves so as much as men need to as
much as the masculine I'm not trying to
pigeonhole men and women I'm putting us
at fault just as much is that you know
they're going and surviving by making
sure that there's food on the table
essentially and we're making sure that
we're survived by being chosen by going
and mutilating our bodies in ways that
we think is going to help that cause but
really it's going to do things like
cause anxiety depression uh it's going
to make us have gut issues hormonal
issues all these things are like a
result of this poisoning that we're
doing to ourselves so we're we're not
that much different like it needs to be
a coming to coming back to what's real
and right which is nature which is what
how things were were born and how where
things came from from you know this
place of Purity and we got to get
ourselves pure which means I'm probably
gonna have to stop the botox eventually
I know but I'm not ready to yes I mean
I'm still waiting for that
that's all I do but I do you know I mean
trust me if you could see how angry my
face got you might be like no you should
probably keep that
um but as more information comes out we
learn and so this is the Forgiveness on
that we have to have for ourselves where
we go look I was doing the best I could
with the information I had and it's
it's totally okay to course correct and
that's what's that's just what's
happening so let's finish off what is
your greatest lesson in 2022 oh boy
um greatest lesson in 2022 I feel is
we're all doing the best we can with
what we know and we're all
subconsciously
enabling and and
pushing this thing along until we don't
you know what I mean so as as each of us
wake up to who we truly are
that shifts and in each of us gets your
labor action each of us work on on
balancing the masculine and feminine
which happens naturally we don't go oh I
need to be a little more feminine today
because you and I both are fire and oh
yeah we have our masculine got a lot of
masculine in US yeah so but again like
as I just start to come closer to who I
really am and do the work and start to
look at my triggers as
um
as signs of what I need to look at it's
all to me it's just embracing who I
really am accepting those parts that
I've been rejecting and denying and and
not facing
um to fully Embrace myself to fully come
back into balance myself so that I can
just energetically then be the change
that I want to see in the world you know
and so that's I think the lesson is like
we're all doing the best that we can
with what we know and I've got to do the
work that I want to see in the world and
that's what I'm doing and what I want to
see in the world is that we all
come back together
um come back into balance and Come Back
To Nature
um and so that's what I'm trying to do
in my everyday life
you're doing a great job
congratulations thank you
hugs so much better like the hugs are so
much better I didn't even expect that
I'm hugging so much tighter people like
okay yeah like the whole torso yes
yes yeah heart to heart now yeah I've
been nothing foreign in between So yeah
thank you thank you thank you thank you
I'm so proud of you and I'm so grateful
for you as a friend I love you love you
too thanks everybody for listening to
the pretty intense podcast today I hope
you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the Subscribe button